PROFESSOR: So we've just
discussed the mass balance that
results from considering
ventilation and breathing
of an infected individual
in a room leading
to a build up and
then steady state
of aerosol droplets that are
infectious in the indoor air.
We've also briefly
talked about masks.
I'd now like to introduce the
possibility of filtration,
which is actually very common in
mechanical ventilation systems.
And then arrive at a
very simple comparison
of filtration versus mask use
as strategies for preventing
indoor transmission.
So here's a schematic
sketch of the air flows.
So basically, we
still have this Q,
which is the outdoor air flow.
So that is the air which is
coming in from the outdoors.
And for mass balance, it
also has to be leaving.
And the air change rate
is based on that Q.
And in fact, if I remember, if
there's a volume V of the room,
then the air change
rate was Q/V. So that's
of units of inverse time.
So that's the time,
roughly, it takes for--
the residence time
for the outdoor air,
and also for the
changing of the air.
Now, in addition to
that, though, there
could be significant
recirculation of air.
Now, if the air is recirculating
but not filtering the droplets
in any way, then
it really doesn't
concern our calculation,
which is basically
just a mass balance.
So if I'm just swirling the
air around, or even taking it
outside and back in,
as long as I'm not
losing some droplets
in the ducts,
then it really doesn't
matter if it's recirculating.
But what is of interest to us
is if in that recirculation
we lose some droplets.
So some droplets
could be lost simply
to settling on the walls
of the ducts or the heating
and ventilation and air
conditioning, HVAC, unit.
But more interesting
is to consider
what would happen if we
actually placed filters, which
is very common in HVAC systems.
So we could either have
one of those big filters
that you stick into the
heating or ventilation ducts.
And those typically
are given MERV
ratings, which are Mean
Efficiency Rating Values.
And we're interested in
the filtration of aerosols.
And so if Pf is the fraction of
the aerosols that are blocked--
and we roughly would look at
a size range, for example,
less than 5 micron radius--
then the difference
of ratings of filters
give you anywhere from
20% to 90% filtration.
And then a very
high quality filter
would be a so-called
Hepa filter,
which is a High Efficiency
Particle Air filtration unit.
And that would give you
even as high as 99.97%.
And also, it's worth emphasizing
that you could also have
a freestanding filtration unit.
There are a variety of different
kinds of filtration units.
It could be a fan which is
blowing through a Hepa filter.
And it could be a
freestanding unit in the room.
It could also be
more exotic systems,
such as electrostatic
precipitators, where the air is
flowing into a chamber that
has a very high electric field,
and the droplets are
basically projected
and deposited onto a surface.
It could be flowing the air
through a UV-concentrated light
treatment to kill the virus.
So you're not actually
removing the droplets, per se,
but you are removing the virus.
And since we've
been keeping track
of the concentration
of virions, they
could be deactivated
in that way.
And so all of that
can essentially
be lumped into this simple
picture of a recirculating flow
rate Qf, and a filtration
efficiency, Pf.
So let's revisit our
equations from last time.
So our mass balance
is at V dC dt
is P, which is the production
rate of infectious air
by an infected person.
We have the removal of air
by the outer flow rate,
which we've already discussed.
And now we have the new
term which is Pf Qf.
So if Pf is 1, then the
entire filtration flow
is removing droplets.
On the other hand, if Pf
is 0, this term goes away.
And that's the limit where
you're simply recirculating
air, but you're not
actually removing
any infectious droplets,
and it's playing no role.
So this is basically
our only new term here.
And so what this means is
we get the same calculation,
same as before, but we just have
to make a little replacement.
What was before Q is now--
notice we can lock-- oops,
I've forgotten, actually,
here there should be
a C here, actually.
Because the flow rate-- or
the flux of infectious air
is the concentration
of infectious air, so
the concentration of virions
per volume times the flow rate,
that thing gives me
the correct value.
So the Pf a dimensionless
number between 0 and 1.
So anyway, Q gets
replaced by Q plus Pf Qf.
And also, wherever we
saw a lambda a, that gets
replaced by lambda a just
from the outdoor air plus
lambda f, where
lambda f is Qf over V.
So that's the recirculating
or filtration air change.
So it's the recirculation or
filtration air change rate,
whereas lambda a is the
outdoor air change rate.
And we can also talk about
the balance between these two.
And so that's also something
which is reported or measured
for ventilation systems.
And that's sometimes
called Z, which
is the outdoor air fraction.
So that would be lambda a
over lambda a plus lambda f.
Or we could also write
it as Q over Q plus Qf.
This is the outdoor air fraction
of the ventilation system.
So another way to
talk about ventilation
is you give the total flow rate.
So as I sketched
here, there could
be a fan which is in the
heating, ventilation,
and air conditioning unit,
which is just pumping out
air at a certain rate.
That air is mixing
the recirculated air
and the fresh air with
a fraction Z, which
is the outdoor air fraction.
And so actually, this might be,
for example, a typical value
is around 20% for
many indoor spaces,
such as businesses
or classrooms.
And basically, you have
to tune this number
to make sure that
enough fresh air is
coming in for the
occupants that are present.
And also, you don't want
this number too high,
because typically the outdoor
air is not comfortable air.
It either is too cold or too
hot or has the wrong humidity.
And so you save a lot of energy
in your heating ventilating
system by keeping this number
as low as it can be effectively,
so that you're just
recirculating quality air that
is at the right temperature
and the right humidity.
However, that desire to save
energy, and hence also save
carbon emissions and
other related things,
goes against what we're
talking about here,
though, is that when
you recirculate the air
and you don't take
in fresh air, it's
actually much worse for
any airborne pathogens that
might be transferred.
So there's a
competition here where
you design an air ventilation
system to make sure
that you're saving energy,
but also that you're
keeping the place safe for
potential airborne transmission
of disease.
OK, so if we just
take this change here,
we can replace these
quantities in the result
that we already derived.
So I don't have to go
through all that again,
but I can just say that the
disease transmission rate--
and this would be
in steady state,
just to give us something
concrete to look at--
that's what I called beta bar.
And let's now write
down the same result,
but just make this change here.
So we have Qb squared,
that's the breathing rate.
We have Cq, that's the
concentration of infection
quanta per volume in the exhaled
breath of a sick individual,
an infected individual.
There was Pm squared.
I'll write different colors
just to emphasize that.
And then in the denominator,
we had lambda a, but now
it's going to be lambda
a plus Pf lambda f--
and I'll write that
in a separate color
in just a moment-- times volume.
So here's Pf.
So now, in this formula, we
have the effects of masks
and the effects of air
filtration together.
And so we can ask
the question that I
posed at the beginning
is, which one
is more effective in stopping
airborne transmission
of disease?
So you can see these two
factors do come in differently
in the equations.
So let's first consider
the effect our filtration--
effective air filtration.
So there's a lot
of interest today
in installing Hepa filters or
other high quality filtration
systems into vulnerable spaces,
such as nursing homes, and also
in spaces such as classrooms,
where people fear transmission
of COVID-19.
So we can ask how
effective that can be.
So one way look at that
would be to say, well,
how does air filtration affect
the steady transmission rate?
So that would be looking
at the transmission rate
with the filter compared
to the transmission
rate without the filter.
So if we do that, you can
see all the terms here
cancel except for this
one that has Pf in it.
And so what we're left with
is, because in the denominator
we're left with just--
when Pf is equal to
0, it's just lambda a.
That's in the denominator, so
it ends up in the numerator.
And so it's just lambda a over
lambda a plus Pf lambda f.
So the benefit of filtration
can be immediately seen right here.
If you know the ratio
lambda a to lambda v,
because I can also
write this as 1 plus--
well, actually, I won't even--
I won't do that right now.
But you can see how
this is related.
It's related to this quantity
Z. but basically, the ratio
of the lambda a to
lambda v is related to Z.
And that obviously
comes in here.
And Pf comes in as well.
But an interesting
question we can ask
is, well, what if you
have a perfect filter?
So let's say we have something
even better than Hepa.
Let's say it's 100% filtration.
That's like best case scenario.
So this fraction here is larger
than if I just set Pf equals 1.
So this is a perfect filter.
So we have the most expensive
filter on the planet,
and it's going to definitely
filter everything.
And so what we're
left with, then,
is just lambda a over
lambda a plus lambda f.
Now I can make the
connection here.
That is simply Z. So basically,
the effect of air filtration
is never better than the
outdoor air fraction itself.
But I already told you, the
outdoor air fraction here
cannot be too small or you're
not delivering enough oxygen
to the occupants of the room.
So basically, there are
standards for that as well.
For example, you need to
have, for outdoor air,
there is an additional
requirement is that you need,
at least in the United
States, 15 cubic feet
per minute per person.
So basically, this Q
can't be too small,
because you have to be
delivering, essentially,
enough oxygen for a
person to breathe.
And so this is one way
this standard is decided.
And so basically, the
Z can't be that small.
And so if I ask myself, what's
the effect of filtration,
an interesting conclusion
to this calculation
is that this is not really
smaller than about 10
to the minus 1.
So if we just think of an order
of magnitude, roughly speaking,
gaining a factor of 10,
maybe, out of air filtration,
but not that much more.
Now, you might say,
how is that possible?
My filter is a perfect filter.
I'm filtering everything.
The problem is seen right
here, is that in reality,
what we really want is we
want to protect a person who's
over here, maybe
who is susceptible,
from another person over
here who is infected.
And you see the problem is
that if it's a well-mixed room,
then the infected
person is breathing
all these infectious
droplets everywhere.
And this other person
is breathing them.
And even if you perfectly filter
the piece of the flow rate
that is going
through the filter,
there's still lots of
other air in the room
and it's not all being removed.
So unfortunately, you
don't get such a benefit
from that, unless
you could completely
choke off the outdoor air
and just keep recirculating
until you remove all the virus.
But then a problem is, you
also run out of oxygen,
and you don't have very
good air in the room.
So that's not really
a solution either.
So basically, air
filtration is helpful,
but I would say it's
not super helpful.
A factor of 10 is good,
we like factors of 10.
But it's not a factor of 100.
And we might actually
rather have a factor of 100.
So then we can ask ourselves,
well, what do we get from masks
And by this, I mean
everybody's wearing a mask.
So keep in mind,
we never know who's
the infected person
ahead of time.
So we want to
consider a case where
everybody's wearing a mask.
And so then by assumption,
the infected person
is wearing a mask, and
any susceptible person
is also wearing a mask.
So that's our assumption here.
OK, so this is good
mask compliance here.
And so we can ask
ourselves again,
what is the transmission
rate with mask
compared to the transmission
rate when there are no masks?
And the way my
notation works here,
Pm is the mask
penetration factor.
So that would actually--
Pm equals 1, actually.
That would be the case where,
basically, there is no mask,
because all the airflow
goes in and out of the mouth
without any kind of filtration.
So this is just Pm squared.
And the important thing
is that it's squared.
So one argument you will hear,
which even influenced the World
Health Organization
back in January
at the beginning
of the pandemic,
is that the virus is so small,
as we've already discussed,
and probably is going to be
carried in very small droplets.
And therefore, any
filtration, even a mask,
is not really that helpful,
because masks are not
going to be filtering at the
scale of 120 nanometers, which
is a virus.
And even the smallest aerosol
droplets, many of them
do get through.
In fact, when you get to
about 1/10 of a micron,
or 100 nanometers,
most mask materials
don't have good filtration.
The very simple
reason is they also
have to allow good airflow.
So if you have such tiny pores
that you're catching things
at that scale, the problem is
there's a very high resistance
to flow and you can't breathe.
In fact, you've
probably experienced
that if you're wearing a good
mask that you can't wear it
for too long,
because after a while
you can't breathe anymore.
So you need to have some big
enough pores to allow flow.
And that makes it really hard to
filter the smallest particles.
But the interesting thing is
this thing comes in squared.
So we can ask ourselves, well,
what about different qualities
of masks?
So a really good mask material
that is perfectly fitting,
so like a high quality
surgical or N95 mask,
if you don't have
any leakage of air,
you have a really good fit,
and you're just going right
through the material,
this could be
as high as 99% filtration for
aerosols, for the aerosols
that we care about.
And this would be like a high
quality surgical mask material,
like not even
factoring for the fit.
So if it's 99% filtration,
what that means is Pm is 0.01,
but it comes in squared.
And so this factor is
actually 10 to the minus 4.
Four orders of
magnitude compared
to one order of magnitude
you get from the filter.
Now, that's for perfect
masks, really good masks.
What if our mask is not so good?
So actually, we have an N95.
N95 actually is guaranteed
to filter about 95%
of the aerosols.
And so if you take
0.05 and square it,
you're getting a number
of order 10 to the minus 3
for Pm squared.
And what about cloth masks?
So this is where
the debate comes in,
because these days people are
wearing cloth masks, which
makes a lot of sense.
It's way better than nothing,
as we'll see in a moment.
But yeah, one could argue,
well, a lot of the cloth masks
might be letting through
these aerosol droplets.
They're not really that great.
In fact, if you look
at the cloth masks,
they could give you a range,
but it might be anywhere from--
I mean a really bad
cloth mask is 10%.
That'd be like just a single,
thin, cotton, very loose weave,
like on a bandana.
That's pretty bad.
But most of the multi-layer
cloth masks, or the silk masks,
they can actually
do pretty well.
They can even get as high as
90%, which is pretty high,
but it's possible.
And maybe a lot of
them, depending on maybe
they're not fitting so well,
they might be more like,
let's say, 50%.
But the thing is,
this comes in squared.
And interestingly, even
the 90% case, that's 10%
get through, so Pm is 10%.
But when you square 10%,
it's still 10 to the minus 2.
And if you take these lower
numbers and square them,
you're still talking
about something
which is on the order
of 10 to the minus 1.
So what this calculation
tells you is that even
like some of the worst
masks you can wear,
as long as there's good
compliance and everybody
is actually wearing
those masks indoors,
then the fact that
this comes in squared
means that you get
at least a factor
of 10 reduction in
the transmission
compared to having no
masks in a well-mixed room.
And in fact, decent
masks will do way better.
You could get a factor of 100,
1,000, or potentially 10,000
in reducing the transmission
rate by wearing masks,
whereas with filtration,
even with the most
expensive and highest
quality filters,
you can barely get better
than a factor of 10.
So this is a really important
concept to keep in mind.
And it comes out of a
really simple calculation.
And the simple reason
that I mentioned before
is that air filtration is only
filtering part of the air,
and the rest is just out
there for you to breathe.
But masks are much better
because they capture the source
and they also block the target.
So that basically,
every droplet has
to go through the
mask on one end
and it has to go through
it again on the other end.
Whereas the filter is
missing most of the droplets.
They're floating
around the room.
They're not going
through the filter.
Unless you choke off the outdoor
air, and you can't do that.